[Musique]
en tant qu'exécuteur testamentaire
d'adriano
je suis tenu de vous lire une
déclaration rédigée de sama cécilia je
sais que notre relation a connu des
moments difficiles mais je pensais que
tu essaierait de me parler au lieu de
fuir
ça va aller
et ce qui lui est arrivé il s'est ouvert
les veines selon ses dernières volontés
vous recevrez 5 millions de dollars et
il ya bien sûr une petite condition
vous ne devez pas être déclarés
mentalement inapte c'est complètement
absurde
quoi adrienne se serait jamais ceux-ci
des écoutes a retrouvé sa liberté c'est
ça qui compte
le laisse pas tenté ya quelqu'un
[Musique]
je perds tu as plus aucune raison
d'avoir peur de lui
c'était un sociopathe il contrôlait tout
absolument tout
je disais que je pouvais toujours
m'enfuir mais qu'il me retrouverais et
puis s'approcherait de moi et que je le
verrai même pas ça va quelqu'un est
assis dans le fauteuil
j'étais coupé quelque chose qui peut
prouver que ce que je subis des griefs
fais toi et d adrian est mort je suis
l'année chez lui jamar j'ai une urne
remplie de cendres moi ça me suffit il a
découvert un moyen de se rendre
invisible
la seule chose encore plus
extraordinaire que de réussir à devenir
invisible on serait d'avoir imaginé un
moyen de vous torturer
au delà de la mort le vrai génie
d'adriano c'était de manipuler les gens
s'approchent pas je suis pas folle vous
voulez dire que la personne qui veut
vous tuer
dans cette pièce avec nous ce qu'on ne
peut pas l'avoir écouté
on souhaite voir
tu dois te voilà